show you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey anthony o'neil number
one best-selling author and ramsey
personality is my co-host today here on
the ramsey show
as we take your questions about your
life and your money
we've done that now for about 25 years
it's a free call and some say the advice
is worth what you pay for it the phone
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
this is god's and grandma's ways
of handling money in a bygone era in
this nation we used to call that common
sense
but now common sense is like having a
superpower
and we got plenty of it around here and
we dish it out because
this culture is sadly lacking in common
sense in moral structure
in just general ability to talk to each
other and be human beings
but the good news is we are here we are
still here and we are not going anywhere
last week we announced that um we are
now the fifth
show in podcast history we've been
hovering around number four number five
podcast in the world for
quite a while we're now the fifth show
to have one
billion downloads of the show
wow that's like a thousand million man
listen that's
wow that boggles my mind considering i
couldn't even spell podcast a while back
and now i are one so there you go one
billion one of five shows to ever have
that happen we've counted up over a half
a billion dollars in debt free screams
on the air we sure did have happened
that we've been able to track
which that means that at least 50
billion
in that at least uh 10x that that never
called in i mean think about if
one per screen yes how many out there do
we never meet never hear about you've
got a
it's a guesstimate but you have no idea
right
there's now about 12 million of you
listening daily on the podcast
and about just under 11 million of you
listening on the radio
and on youtube watching on youtube and
so
upward of 22 million of you out there
today
that blows this hillbilly's mind
i have no idea if i if i had thought
about that i'd just get nervous
not really but uh congrats dave man you
know what it is if you just keep doing
the right thing a long long time
yes sir you're gonna piss some people
off yep and if you
keep doing the right thing a long long
time you're gonna help a whole lot of
people
yeah and the whole lot of people you
help are gonna far offset the few people
that you piss off so
and pissing people off is a bit of a
gift i have so and here's the thing dave
if everyone likes everything you're
doing you're doing nothing at all
if everyone likes everything that you're
doing then you're doing nothing
at all that's a success principle right
there only one way to avoid criticism
aristotle said it say nothing do nothing
and be nothing i said look at you man
i love it well that's the kind of stuff
you're going to get around here
grandma's common sense and grandma's
head
hand up the back side of your head if
you're goofing off
that's uh that's what grandma did at my
house she'd cuff us you're everyone hit
you in the back of the head i mean my
mom just did that the other day
[Laughter]
what'd you do hey you didn't take your
plate to the sink hey listen man i got
12 million people listening right now
kelly's staring at me so i'm ah i'm
gonna keep that between me and my mother
well you brought it up i didn't bring it
up it's full disclosure here
now you know the only way you can pop
somebody in the back of the head
is if you got your arm around the
shoulder hey you're right and she
definitely had her arm around my
shoulder so only
only people that only people that love
you
yes position themselves in your life to
correct you yeah
and if you're not positioned in my life
to correct me
don't bother and try we bail our hate
mail here i
use it for kindling all winter yeah we
don't and we answer every letter that
comes in
to ramsey solutions and we have since
day one except
hate mail yes because the only answer to
it is
there's not an answer yeah because you
didn't really want an answer you just
wanted to
[ __ ] about something yeah so like me
saying [ __ ] about it let's shall get
hate mail for that one right
so there you go because i'm i'm way too
christian for the non-christians and i'm
well not christian enough for the
christians but happily right here in the
middle baby that's why i like rocking
with you dave you know cause we just
gonna be
real yeah well that's for sure we ain't
got time to be anything else life's too
short
i'm getting old i've got that old man
syndrome now well you said that not me
i said it's a syndrome i didn't say it
was an old man
the younger people looking at you like
out there in the lobby
you're getting old yeah yeah yeah yeah
anthony he young keep it up i'm gonna
hit you in the back of the head
but dave i gotta ask you this question
over the years last year's if god would
have told you hey in 20 years you're
going to help
millions of people you're going to have
billions of download
what would your what would you have said
to god then i'm curious
you know we've had that discussion a lot
me and him and um
i'm really grateful he didn't do it all
at once because i wouldn't have had the
character to carry it
he's incrementally built the muscles wow
a little bit at a time every year yeah
it took forever to get 100 radio
stations and it took forever to get to
200 then it took forever to get 300 and
now we're at 644.
and it took forever and every one of
them was a dog fight every one of them
was a scratch
and you know and you know we were on
sirius xm then we weren't then we were
on
we were on sirius and xm when they were
two separate companies and then we
weren't
and we've been on this radio station
that radio station and then we weren't
and then we're back on it
uh you know we just have outlasted a
whole lot of people is where it amounted
to
uh that thought that i had one guy on
radio this is great
he called me from uh mississippi
and he said i'm gonna have to take you
off the air and uh this is back when we
were smaller probably had 40 50 stations
and so i was talking to him personally
and so he's got to take you off there
and i'm like man what are you taking me
off there
for he goes i can't stand the liability
i said liability i'm not saying anything
that's going to make you liable i mean
i'm telling people how to get out of
debt how do you think you're going to
get a sued for that
and he goes no your show is so boring
somebody's going to fall asleep while
they're driving in a wreck
he was dead serious too
oh canceled me and um you know we're
still in the business now he's not but
um
that's how it works out best the best
revenge is success right you just keep
going you just don't stop and you don't
stop
and and here's the thing if you ever
stop being who you're supposed to be
yeah in order to keep the mob happy yeah
the mob will you're over you're done
yeah yeah
so you you can't apologize enough for
the mob yeah you can't
uh adjust your optics or your message
enough for the mob so
have some principles folks and stick to
them over an extended period of time
and you'll become wealthy you will build
a quality marriage you will raise
children that will rise up and call you
blessed as the bible says you will
build a business that where the team
loves you and you love your team
you will do the when you continually do
the right thing on principle
not optics not the way it looks over an
extended period of time is the only way
you will find your way to
any level of success so when you ask us
a question
in these next few segments about your
money
it's not going to be based on what feels
good because
children do what feels good adults
devise a plan and follow it so anthony
and i are always going to lead you
any of the ramsey personalities and i
are always going to lead you on a
journey of principle here's the
principle here's the law of gravity
now honey if you jump off a building
it's going to hurt it's a law of gravity
don't do that
don't do that then you call me up and
you go well dave i jumped off the
building you told me not to
now how old am i gonna do i don't know
man you broke your leg now what we gonna
do we gotta figure out the next thing
we'll fix we'll pick you up wherever you
are
but it's gonna be on principle that
we're giving you guidance and if you
can't handle that
don't walk in the kitchen baby don't do
it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 i am dave ramsey david
is in salt lake city hi david how are
you
hi dave doing well how are you guys
doing better than we deserve what's up
in your world
yeah i have a question for you i'm a
full-time student in a master's of human
resources program at my local university
i've been doing your hustle program i'm
going to graduate debt free in december
with a little bit of savings have a job
lined up
my my current job told me that
if i have an mba so if i did an mba
though
i taught me 6 000 more a year and the
nba is going to take me an extra
semester and
24 20 000 more on student debt and i'll
lose my savings i wonder what your guys
thoughts were on that
i'm sorry you have to go into debt to do
it
yeah yeah you can't hustle your way
through it
that's an expensive semester too yeah
really 20 000 bucks for a semester
that's ridiculous now are you sure
that's a semester
is that a year i've i've never heard of
a semester it costs
20 000 you have yeah vanderbilt's more
than that a semester
goodness gracious but anyway you're not
going to vanderbilt so what are you
what's the deal i mean you're not going
to
freaking mit either what's the thing i
mean why is it so stinking expensive
it's part of the differential tuition
they have at some business schools
yeah that's what i thought so they're
charging you again
for a lot of the classes you already
took that they're going to count towards
your mba that's what that is
right correct yeah correct that's called
bs
um that's not mba that's different um
[Laughter]
uh i want you to get the mba i don't
want you to go into debt to do it right
and i want you to not to overpay
for it so we've got two wrong answers in
the equation out of three
um how about uh your new job pays for it
i don't know i i've talked about maybe
doing some
classes online maybe considering working
in january started working and paying as
i go to finish the mba yeah some of the
better mba programs are actually not
full-time student programs they're
actually adult ed
yeah and they're for people for
executives to add an mba on
while they're working so like night
classes and so forth
and some online classes and your current
employer pays the tuition for fun as a
employee benefit i think that would be
the way i would go
in other words i'm not let i'm not
letting this school rip me off because
that's that's a ripoff
yeah so let's let's pursue the mba
some other way somewhere else at a more
reasonable cost
and maybe your employer picks it up as
an employee benefit
and no debt yeah but the but the nba is
not
necessary for you to win in life okay uh
and very few places this must be a very
large company very few places pay more
for an mba
they pay more for the knowledge that you
get while you got the mba and as you
apply that in the marketplace but very
few places
actually i don't pay more i got a
thousand employees i don't pay a dime
more for an mba i pay for what you do
your raise is effective when you are
yeah and now david now this is this a
career that you plan on being in for the
rest of your life
as well i i mean i do i
see it's a company that i could grow
with pretty substantially cool great
then i agree with dave we got to figure
out how do we get this mba
without going into twenty thousand
dollars in debt in a semester i mean
it's just foolishness for me i guess
i haven't heard it because people don't
come to me saying that because they know
i'm telling them no that's stupid
but in your case i agree with dave we
need to figure out how to do it so i
would immediately go back to your job
ask them
hey i'm willing to get it but are there
any initiatives here like can i get a
tuition reimbursement do you all have
any programs
well there's got to be other schools in
salt lake that are doing some adult ed
stuff
absolutely and adult i mean vanderbilt
has a great adult
program for an mba here in town a bunch
of people been through it yeah that are
friends and so forth i don't
know that we've got one a graduate
working here we might i don't have any
idea but
um of that program but lots and lots of
schools have
uh you know adult follow-through mbas
uh because it is a good the reason is
not necessarily the actual degree
and the value of it in the marketplace
the reason is the knowledge base that
you gain while you study for it is
valuable
got you uh for instance the mba is on
our team i don't have an mba
right i've got a phd in dunb but um
but the uh but the the mbas on our team
have taught
me and other team members other leaders
in this place over the last
decade about strategic thought yeah i'm
a scratch claw get down the ditch
find something kill it drag it home
tactical entrepreneur i
i get stuff done man and uh but but
that's
sometimes you're just running in circles
because you don't have a plan while
you're getting stuff done and it's just
sheer activity is your survival rate
if you'll do strategic thought with your
activity and your work ethic
you do a lot better and mbas have taught
us a lot about strategic thoughts so we
actually spend
a fair amount of time on strategic
planning here i agree uh but it's all
learned from that skill set and so
that's a an example of something that is
very valuable actually turns into real
dollars in the marketplace
but uh it's not i didn't do it because
he had an mba i did it because he or she
convinced me that this is good
a good critical thinking skill set that
we're missing out on things at the
company if we don't do it yeah
and so but you don't get raises in most
places now again big corporate america
yeah they're gonna
where you went to school might matter
one of the few places
99 of places you deal with don't care
where you went to school and they don't
care if you've got graduate work
but they do care if you're smart so
education is vital but we pay cash for
it
as anthony says in the book debt-free
degree so that's david that's what we
would do
that's how we'd work out it's a really
really good question and a good rant to
get us on
steve's in rutland vermont hi steve how
are you
i'm not bad i'm a big fan of yours i've
been listening to it for years and thank
you ed you took my call like
someone's gonna get on your phone i'm
honored how can we help
okay i am a retired engineer
um one kid graduated college
and one's still in college both of them
had college funds that i fully funded
to pay for that degree so i'm pretty
much debt-free but here's my great
question
the question i have is i'm selling some
property in a ski resort town
and now i'm going to be going and
finding my re retirement home
in florida because you have to pay a
state income tax and everybody knows the
common things
should i take out a loan or not i asked
td bank
and they said if i had 99 000 of income
shown
they'll give me uh two point three six
percent
and my financial institution was talking
about
um two point six five percent i thought
question is it worth just writing a
check
buying the house that i want to retire
in same 68 maybe our last 15 years
to take a 15-year mortgage or a 30-year
mortgage
or just pay to check in
no mortgage okay i'm a little confused
i'm a little confused how long did you
say you've been listening to us
uh for almost a little over a year now
okay all right cool well we appreciate
you being i love your discussions on the
phone during the time
have you ever heard us say tell somebody
to borrow money
uh you seem to be against it
[Laughter]
yeah that would be uh that would be true
and the reason
the reason is stability and peace
versus the risk that borrowing adds to
your equation
and so um i own uh uh
vacation property as well i'll just put
it under that category
and it sure is a different thing to own
one of them
uh when there's no debt on it uh when
they call you up and go
oh there was a little storm down here
so you're going to sell those and you
have the cash to pay cash for your
retirement house and so
i do have the cash around here that
would be known as a no-brainer yeah go
go go pay cash man uh thanks for
listening to us though for a year but
absolutely the only time we're going to
say to borrow money is when you get your
first mortgage
and then once you pay off that mortgage
we're going to really tell you don't go
back into debt
you know bottom line and the reason is
is that it gives you stability
particularly in your retirement years in
your wealth building in your life
to not have any money borrowed
yes y'all remember when this thing
happened
called a pandemic 12 months ago and
y'all were all scared
of losing your jobs and losing
everything and economic collapse you all
remember that
that was 20 minutes ago people so let me
tell you build your house out of bricks
not straw or sticks and that's called
debt free so that's how we're going to
advise you steve thank you for being in
our audience sir
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
is my co-host today in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
johnny and daniella is are with us is it
daniela or danella daniella daniella i'm
sorry i knew i was going to mess up
so welcome guys how are y'all doing good
excited
and where do you guys live houston texas
all right and all the way to nashville
to do a debt-free scream
yes sir how much you pay off 192
thousand dollars
oh how long did that take uh 34 months
good for you man you've been getting it
yes and your range of income during that
time
uh 110 to 160. good what do you guys do
for a living
i'm a police officer and i'm an
assistant in a cancer research
laboratory
okay and you've both been working lots
of ot
he has anything that came up right
anything and everything i was working
about 70 to 80 hours a week
i'm thinking 34 months wow
yeah well thank you amazing what kind of
debt was the 192 000
uh it was everything dave we had two
cars medical bills
um personal loans personal loan hospital
bill but the biggest
was student loans we had 120 000 student
loans together
so you were like normal yes very a
little too normal actually
two too normal yeah a lot like going on
with your normal but yeah oh my gosh man
yeah you i mean when you added all that
up did you about have a freaking heart
attack
uh it's very it was very scary we sat
down and we didn't know how much it was
and we found out
we we thought it was impossible wow
that's too big a mountain yeah it's
overwhelming
and you yeah you did it in 34 months
under three years oh by the way one of
those years was a pandemic
yes yeah just throw that in for the
spice and the gumbo
well that created a lot of ot for him
too so yes
yeah i guess i didn't think about that
that's true wow
well way to go so tell us the story how
did you start all this
our oldest daughter we have two
daughters our oldest one was just
turning one
and i i love being a police officer
loving a husband but the best thing in
my entire life is being a father
and i wanted more children and when our
daughter turned one we had her in
daycare and we were like hey let's start
with time for the second one
and we were looking at our finances and
with two daycares and just with the
bills we had
we had no money left and we just yeah we
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
and we are broke
right and we just bought a story yes we
just bought a house and we were
completely house broke
and we did not know where any of our
money went wow
so what'd you do so uh basically i heard
your name twice in one week
and i was like okay let me give this day
ramsey thing a try uh
one guy has four one police officer
right now has four kids i was like wow
how are you doing this he goes well
we're doing the
baby steps and dave ramsey and i had
never heard of you before
and then one of my best friends i was
paying off this car like four years
early
and he said something about baby steps
and dave ramsey i was like okay
i'm getting the hand let me let me see
what this dave ramsey guy's about god is
whispering in your ears
so uh we were going on i was going on a
guy's cruise with some other officers
and uh i took the total money makeover
with me figured maybe i'll read it if i
can sleep at night
and uh so the first half of that that
cruise was very fun i was spending money
like normal
completely and then uh i couldn't sleep
because the rocking
and i burned through your book in
probably about a night and a half and
the second half of that cruise was like
what am i doing
so i definitely controlled my spending
and when we got back i
told my wife so we got to do this now
were you on board when he told you that
no oh yes i was completely i'm the nurse
not on board not on board the boat
yeah no i was on board with the plan i'm
the nerd and i was doing the excel sheet
and he was the free spirit so he was
just spending money like crazy and then
when he came back from the
from the cruise he uh he was like he was
just showing me all these pictures we
can do this
i'm like i've been waiting for you to do
this for so long
and then right after the cruise harvey
happened and so he worked all this
overtime i didn't see him for
a whole week wow and that first overtime
check
uh we completed baby step two and
knocked out three credit cards
one sorry one sorry i got you i knew
where you're going i was about to say
that that was a big change
wow that's so fun y'all now throughout
this journey
i'm curious what was the hardest thing
with you all you two look very young
have two beautiful young children um um
you were making good money but i'm
pretty sure something was difficult what
was the hardest thing throughout this
journey
uh the hardest part was just being away
i had a one-year-old daughter and i mean
working 60 to 70 hours
um a week or 78 hours a week i was gone
a lot of the time i worked nights so my
overtime was during the day and i'd be
sleeping in the afternoon and we'd
basically be
two ships passing in the night i'd be
finishing overtime
going to sleep and then it was time to
go to work yeah
wow yeah the hardest thing for me was
not seeing him raising
raising our first daughter and and just
him missing all the milestones but
we knew this was worth it we completely
knew
but he's there forever now oh yes now
it's amazing now
now with our second daughter now he's
going through all the baby like mild
state
smile steps with us and he's like wow i
missed a lot i'm like yeah but
now we're here and now we're free wow
you'll be all right you got it man you
got it and you got you
when they know you're there you're going
to be there right oh yeah that was that
was the best that was the noting
they're so young they don't even know
let me get all this knocked out real
quick
yeah then you don't have to miss a ball
game or do anything exactly because
you're working overtime to pay debt
i mean that's just good for you man well
done you guys
okay your rock stars you did it you paid
off 192
000 in 34 months all right you
you're not someone with an opinion
you're someone who's actually done
something
so your input is valid what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
uh for me it's two things one is keep
track of your progress we have a
debt free board a progress board that we
did every month
without fail i look forward to every at
the end of the month putting our
it's only stickers but every sticker
represent a hundred dollars and we put
so many stickers a month i look forward
to that every month because as hard as i
was working i knew i was building more
and more
towards the end and the second thing is
stay connected
the facebook uh group is so amazing
because there's someone winning on there
every single day so the baby steps
facing facebook yes yeah
there's someone completing baby step one
you're like wow look how far we got
we've come do you remember when we did
one
or there's someone paying off their
house i'm like wow we cannot wait to get
there
so we went through fpu twice once the
beginning of baby step two
and once when we were almost done and
it's it's two different um
ways of looking at it because i mean one
is a theory you're like maybe this thing
will work and then at the end of it
you're like
now we're looking for baby step seven
and everything else
yeah very powerful well done you guys
one more question before we let you do
your debt free scream and before i ask a
question
johnny thank you so much for serving man
yeah um i know police officers sometimes
uh don't hear that enough and i want to
say thank you thank you thank you for
doing what you're doing
and risking your life to go out there
and protect us
to that young person that is graduating
college and about to walk into the world
and they're getting bombarded with all
these opportunities to get the credit
cards to get the debt
why would you tell them to avoid it i
would tell them to avoid it because
i mean you go off to your job you're
like i'm making all this money but then
with all these credit cards and all
these extra minimum payments
it just goes away and you're if you
if you just graduated completely work
like you were a college student just
work and work and work go wherever you
got your degree in
work and then once once you paid off
those student loans
you don't have anything else i just
imagine we paid off 192 000
what if we didn't have that and we put
that on our house instead so
all of that was opportunity costs i mean
it could have been going towards other
things
so our goal i'm 34 our goal is to pay
off our house by the time i'm 40. come
on man
and we know that's completely possible
it's six years yeah so we have six years
to do what we did in three years
i love it okay so uh lily and rose
are gonna join us for the debt free
scream or at least
one i think yes the whole one of them is
crying
one up screaming that's okay scream girl
let's hear it
let's hear those lungs i love it well
done you guys well we're so proud of you
we got a copy of rachel cruz's book for
you
know yourself know your money as your
gift and uh way to go you guys
excellent excellent work all right
johnny and
daniella lily and rose from houston
texas 192
000 paid off in 34 months making 110
to 160 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're dead free
wow what a great mom what a great dad
family tree has officially changed
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money
this is the ramsey show the phone number
is triple eight eight two five
five our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping
and when the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code the magic word
ramsay to get the best possible deal
hey dave today's question comes from
sean in wyoming
sean says i recently graduated nursing
school with 19
000 in student loan debt my girlfriend
and i want to get married next year the
hospital
where i will be working at pays 250
a month towards student loans i want to
pay more than that
and have my debt paid off by next year
do you think it is possible
or should i postpone my wedding
um you know dave i think here it's it's
two things one i think yes you should
take advantage of the 250
a month and also add more to that but i
am
not me personally going to tell you to
wait to marry
the love of your life because you are in
debt great
you know um i would definitely say do
what you can
um as far as whatever you can't afford
but then at the same time i want you to
go ahead and pay cash for the wedding
and so if that means you gotta pause a
little bit just to set aside five grand
for the wedding and then jump back in
on it i'm totally with that but uh don't
postpone
the love of your life uh because of
because of your debt
but i do want you to attack attack it as
much as you possibly can
okay what we don't know from his
question is who's paying for the wedding
whether he is or not he just says we
want to get married next year right
my hospital where i'll be working we'll
pay 250 a month which is three thousand
dollars in one year yep
um i want to pay more and have
everything paid off so here's the thing
sean you're just out of school
uh you're been living like a college
student i want you to keep living
like a college student and the great
news
about the nursing field is that you can
work
all you want to work
and so while you're planning the wedding
um you already got her on the hook
because you're engaged
so you can just work like all the time
like that policeman just did yep an hour
you know 80 hours a week
and he paid off 192 000 in three years
now she was working too in that case
right but uh i bet you can knock out the
19
especially if they're going to give you
three so you only got to knock out 16
in one year and still get married yes
all i'm saying is keep your lifestyle to
nothing scorched earth syndrome
beans and rice rice and beans and work
like a freaking maniac yes that's where
money comes from
and the great news about nursing is you
can always work
always take those weekend shifts at the
er they pay big
do some uncomfortable stuff and be done
with this 100
done with it you're completely out of
that and clean when you get married
that would be a whole different way to
get married now we're not saying post
upon the wedding we're just saying work
your butt off
and i would have told you that if you
were married too by the way and i would
have told you that if you were single
and dating by the way
so the whole answer is you make more
money by working more
and keep your lifestyle to nothing by
the way the good news about working all
the time is
you ain't got time to spend money you
know even today do you know when i spend
the most money when i'm bored
oh yeah that's when people start
clicking on that little prime button
that's true on amazon i think i need one
of those i'm not sure what it is but i
need one of those
i'm going to look up crap and make up
something that i don't even know i need
and get me one right
this is what happens when you're bored
but when you're working all the time and
you're you know
when you're all you when you come home
all you got time to do is fall asleep
because you've been working because
you're tired
yeah i wouldn't want to be a workaholic
listen that's not a danger for most
people in our culture
right most people don't work enough
and they don't work while they're at
work there's an idea
you know and all that i mean so you know
just just and let me tell you you're not
going to die from overwork just before
you die you'll pass out yeah
it's okay so i mean you're going to be
all right you're not going to die from
overwork and i'm not suggesting you do
this the rest of your life i'm
suggesting you do it for a very short
time it's a sprint
so that you never have to do it again
you're retraining your whole life
so good dave that's good i mean like you
know we do the same thing around here
even and it's not about making money but
it's about getting momentum to something
like
like when you launch a book yes there's
like a big pile of work right there it's
called a book tour
yeah all the media hits 16 freaking hour
days
yes i mean and they also they all look
alike it's like a groundhog day because
you answer the same question over and
over and over about the same book right
and it's just but you have to be
mentally on emotionally on spiritually
on physically on
because you get fatigued because you're
working your butt off but it's you don't
we don't do that
we don't work we don't work each other
like that oh i don't work like that all
the time
no but i can when i need to to get to a
goal and the reward the sprint yes and
the reward is so refreshing afterwards
the momentum that you get off of it yes
you can spin something up
in your life that that spirals out there
another decade
from a 90-day or 120-day sprint yeah
and that's what we do we launch a book
it's what you do when you get rid of
debt
it's the same kind of stuff natalie's
with us in dayton ohio hi
natalie welcome to the ramsey show how
can we help
hi how are you guys great how can we
help
um so i was wondering should i move out
of my parents house
and rent even though i'm still in debt
um a little bit of background on that is
i'm about 25 000 in debt
but i did graduate with my associates
last year
i currently make 23 000 a year
and i'm about to get a second job that
makes an additional 16.
um i'm wanting to rent because my job is
an hour away
and it's kind of kind of getting to me
for that drive
what is the job so i
am an animal care tech for a reptile
breeding company
a reptile a wee bit specialized are you
uh so what's your what's your uh
what's your vote in your associates in
it's just a general science degree a
general what degree
science science just associates with
science
so you want to work in the animal field
though
yes and this is going to take you
somewhere
beyond 23 000 i assume because that
sucks it should
yeah this is just temporary um but i'm
kind of in a i'm willing to try a lot of
other things i'm getting into a lot of
different careers but right now this is
my stable
job different careers or different jobs
uh careers like i'm i'm learning how to
weld currently
oh so you're not you're not hooked on
the animal thing then yeah
no it's just it's just because a welder
can make 50. yeah
loader can make 75 80 too depending on
where you are and who what you're
welding yeah yeah
yeah that's big time that's good i like
that
okay so this is not um so really moving
for this job that you're probably not
going to be in may not be the thing
right
correct um the the area that it's in
though i would like to stay in um
so it's just i just don't know whether
or not you like the area anyway
okay where the lizard thing is you like
the area anyway
yeah okay how old are you uh natalie
i'm 21. okay okay
you know i think before i move right
i'm advising you i need to figure out
what what's in my next three to five
years
okay i'm not telling you to stay home
and i'm not telling you to move what i'm
saying is
before you do anything major identify
okay
where will i be in the next three to
five years where am i going am i going
to be a welder buy
by then and then what is that path that
i need to take to become a welder or am
i still going to be
in the animal field and then what do i
need to do to get more than 23 000
a year so you know me personally
i would love to see you answer that
question and then when you answer that
question
then i could give you a better answer on
okay should you move out
because if you're saying hey i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna be a welder
i can have all my associate uh all my
degrees out the education out within a
year
and then i can move here i can go do
this then i'm staying
home and i'm gonna go that path yeah
rather than racking up
more bills and i still don't even know
what i'm doing it's not the income it's
not the location and it's not your age
it's the lack of
stability in your plan yes when you get
your plan stable then make your move
yeah that's good and i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you 12 months
you need to stay what you need a stable
plan and a roommate and some money piled
up you may not you won't be out of debt
by then probably
but that won't matter you can you can
still finish because you're not afraid
of work
no i like that you know you're you're a
girl go
i mean from lizards to welding i mean
there you go
that that's a huge work should do
anything yeah that's good that's that's
good
so yeah and pick up a second job for 16k
yeah there you go so you're going to be
all right you know that's not the thing
i do want you to use the home base to
have a stable launch pad from i like
anthony's suggestion a lot
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil number one best-selling author of
the book
debt-free degree ramsey personality and
host of the table a big time exploding
podcast and youtube show
where you can call in and participate in
the conversation around
the table the phone number here if you
want to talk to the folks at this table
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five anthony and i are here to
answer your questions about your life
and your money triple eight eight two
five five two two
five adam is with us adam is in lake
city florida hi adam
welcome to the ramsay show hey dave hey
uh thank you for uh
taking my phone call our pleasure sir
how can we help
i am currently on babysit two and
out of all my debt my vehicle is over
fifty percent of it
so i am trying to sell it i'm thinking
about selling it
what do you have however it's the end of
my
it's the highest thing on my debt
snowball it's the last thing i need to
pay off
what do you owe i owe 17
4 on it and what's it worth about
13 12. the few the few people that i've
reached out to
for a quote have been quoting me between
12 and 14.
okay so that's a wholesale at a dealer
right they're trying to buy the card
wholesale
correct so if you look up kelly blue
book kbb.com
for private sale if you put it on
craigslist that means it's going to
bring 15. yeah
i i believe kelly blue book is running
16 to 18.
there we go so yeah we're fourteen
hundred dollars often
all right so what's your income uh forty
forty thousand eight hundred i'm not
including my side hustle
you said forty thousand eight hundred uh
usually yes sir okay so 41 grand all
right and then you got a side hustle
that makes you what
roughly two thousand a month okay two
rules of thumb we use
one is is the value of your vehicle more
than half your annual income
you do not violate that but you come
close yep
number two can you be 100 debt free if
you keep this thing
other than your home within uh
two years and you probably can do that
yes sir i think my date is july of 2022.
just with your side income you can
probably do it this year yeah
do you like do you like the car i
i don't like the payment more no i know
but do you like the car
yeah um not really i mean
it gets by it gets me by that has to
suck making a car payment on top of
something you don't even like man
yeah well that might be reasonable that
might be reason to move down let me tell
you why
why i came up with a two-year thing and
let this you percolate on this and
anthony you join in
okay but my reasoning is if the car
is going to keep you in debt for an
extended period of time
past the two-year you're trying to run a
race with ankle weights on
okay you're not in that but you're
carrying a fairly heavy weight you got
one brick in your backpack anyway
right and so you got something to carry
here because you're gonna make it but
like you said it's half
of your debt and you can clear that
on something you don't even like that
much anyway then i might do that now
here's the downside here here's the
reason i try to project this out
just past because we don't get people
out of debt just for getting out of that
we get you out of debt so you can become
wealthy
and guess what happens as you become
wealthy you're going to move into a
better car
okay so if you move down out of this car
into a
into a beater and 18 months from now you
move back into another car that you pay
cash for
of similar price which is really about
the schedule you would be on
uh it really was it was you know it's
kind of just a little two-step here
it wasn't like a big deal move yeah now
if you told me you're making 40 and you
owe 50 on the truck
sucker's gone yeah blow it up i mean
it's done
okay you completely screwed up doing
that but that's not your case
so um what kind of car is it adam it's a
truck
chevy silverado sure oh i mean that's a
good that's a good car though yeah
nothing wrong with that truck yeah
nothing around
but he doesn't like it so yeah i'm so
the whole idea is if you're going to
turn around around
18 months later move back up anyway and
you like the car then i would say fight
through and keep the car but you don't
like the car so
you're going to move out of the stupid
thing in 18 months anyway once you're
dead free you're probably going to move
out of it right
correct let's go and move out of it now
and accelerate debt free then
i i agree now what's out of the debt
though adam
i'm sorry what's the other debt uh
credit cards and some personal ones okay
cool great yeah
sell the car man let's go ahead and sell
the car now once you sell the car do you
have cash
to buy another car yeah you got to get
you had a little cash set aside for a
beater
yes right that was the other that was
going to be the follow-up question
yeah you push pause on your baby step to
pile up some cash to transact this right
okay now how do i go about deciding
what price level i need to be saving up
for
i mean i mean i understand it's a beater
and everything but a couple of grand
that's what requires
a couple of grand yeah okay and it may
not be a truck adam what's your side
hustle
i uh deliver groceries through uh a
company
an online company are they requiring a
certain age of car
uh no okay they just require reliability
correct yeah so two to three grand yeah
c3 yeah cause this is not a car you're
gonna keep
it has no sex appeal but has reliability
it's a car you give a name to
okay old blue got me through when i was
getting out of debt and delivering
groceries you tell your grandkids this
story someday i'm back in the day i had
all blue
right yes sir and take pictures of it
because you want to remember the
sacrifice
absolutely i wish i had pictures of some
of those crap cars i drove when i was
straightening this stuff out man
trust me i got mine it motivates me
yeah so but that's what yeah so you hear
all the different variables variable
number one he doesn't like the car
variable number two
it um it's half as debt uh variable
number three he doesn't like the car so
yeah yeah he's got a good side hustle so
yeah bust it pile up three grand four
grand
1400 to cover the the whole three grand
to buy you a little something
and let's put this thing on craig's list
get her sold and uh don't buy something
till you get her sold
yeah and and then just work like crazy
to get out of that while you're waiting
to get it sold when it sells
don't give it away we're not trying to
sell do not sell it for wholesale
there's no reason you're not about to be
repo'd
so don't give away don't sell a 16 000
truck for 12 000 to a dealer right
and create another 4 000 problem for
yourself there's no point in that the
dealer's not doing anything wrong
they're just trying to make a living but
they they buy cars cheap so they can
make a
make a profit when they resell them they
don't buy them at retail and let me say
this to america i know you probably hear
some of you all who are new to us
dave did not say skip over the the small
debt and go pay off the card
what he's saying is good still worth the
baby steps but while you're working the
baby step method paying off all you did
from smaller to largest
sell the vehicle so he's not putting no
more money on top of that one
but in order to do that we really put
baby step two on hold for a second
exactly pile up cash to get the car in
to do the other but then that releases
him
from this larger debt right so in a
sense the 1400
hole he is in becomes an item in the
debt snowball
and moves to the front there it is
that's in a sense what we're doing we're
instead of the whole seventeen thousand
dollar debt yes
it's the fourteen dollar 1400 hole and
so that's that's the way i
the logic flow works on this the
critical thinking
skills yeah adam you're good man you're
good you got this baby
knock it out man knock it out
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt no matter what your goals
are the army national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
nearly 1 in 10 people relocated last
year and that was just in 2020 in the
middle of a pandemic and that means that
this year there's a good chance you or
someone you know
is planning to move now i know it feels
like there's a thousand unknowns you're
juggling when you're relocating but you
cannot lose focus on one of the most
important
personal and financial factors in your
move
housing i recommend hiring a quality
real estate agent like one of our
endorsed local providers or elps to help
you
find the right home in your new city
a lot of these markets are quite hot
right now
hard to find a property without
overpaying
all kinds of garbage going on and elps
are the top performing experts in their
local market they have years of
experience they're high octane high
protein they'll help you
get it done without you getting in some
kind of a weird bidding war or something
it's easy to get instantly connected
with an endorsed local provider agent
text
house to 33 789 to talk with a ramsey
trusted
agent about how they can help with your
relocation that's
house text house two three three
seven eight nine open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
joseph is with us in louisville kentucky
hi joseph how can we help
hi dave uh anthony how are you all doing
today better than we deserve
what's up outstanding so my wife is a
teacher and we just moved from
georgia where she was contributing to
the georgia teacher retirement system
and a 403 b because she was being a
match from the school system
we have recently moved to the louisville
kentucky area so she moved her funds
from the teacher retirement system
to the 403b uh since she can no longer
contribute to that teacher retirement
system
her new school system doesn't offer any
kind of 403 b
match when she's still required to
contribute
to the kentucky teacher retirement
system
we don't really know what to do with her
403b now since there's no match and she
has to make the mandated contribution to
the kentucky trs
we only plan on living in kentucky for
another two to three years
so should we use the 403 b to roll the
kentucky trs funds into when we leave
like we've been in georgia
then she can just like match her roth
ray instead while she's here
no i think this might be the right move
now i just want to left and right let me
check no it's not
um here's the thing you're military so
you're moving all the time and that
means
she's gonna constantly be having this
question
every time she moves careers every time
every time anybody out there listening
moves a job
always take any retirement with you
that you can take and roll it
to an individual ira
if it's a if it's a roth ira a 401k or a
roth 403 b you're coming out move it to
a roth if it's a traditional
like in this case it's pre-tax you're
going to move that to an
individual roth and if
i mean an individual ira if you move it
to an individual ira there are no taxes
so what you're telling me is the georgia
retirement
gave her a lump sum and moved it into
her georgia 403 b
right uh it's an independent quarter of
3d
throughout through a uh just do an
insurance company
and the kentucky is mandatory
contribution to a
403 b correct it's a mandatory
contribution to the kentucky teacher
retirement system well i guess i got
like a 4018 or two
okay so it's not on a 403 b no sir but
they allowed me to roll that 401a from
the georgia trs
to a yeah i would not do that have you
done that already
yes sir i did okay well you can still
move it the good news
about okay a 401k you cannot roll out of
while you still work there
a 403b you can roll out of
while you still work there so anything
in kentucky you can get into that 403b
get it in there so you can roll it out
almost immediately
into a rollover ira so go to
daveramsey.com click smart vester
find a smart investor pro in your area
in kentucky
where you are and sit down with them
they'll verify
what i'm telling you but any money
you've got in a 403 b
anywhere you can and should immediately
roll
to an individual ira the beauty of this
is you don't have to just do hopscotch
every time you move
you've got one account with your smart
investor pro
and each of the in each of the times you
do a rollover will have a different
account number within your main account
within your master account
but you will still have all of your
money in one place being managed with
your
with you telling it what to do with it
with a good smartvestor pro and every
time you get any money loose from
anything
now the kentucky stuff when is she
vested in that
when she leaves so
uh she starts consuming the kentucky trs
the day that she starts her the
day that she gets her first paycheck
yeah until she terminates
her employment with anywhere in kentucky
when she terminates can she take it with
her
she can indeed take it with her and so
what you're saying is the idea is to
not roll that 401 a into a 403 b
when we leave no roll it to an ira
roll it's hot our array okay every time
because
what you're going to end up with let's
say you live in 10 different places
she's going to have 10 different
accounts without
with iras all in one master account
where you're managing one set of
investments all exactly the same way
instead of going from lame 403 b to lame
403 b because most of these 403 bs the
options in them are insurance based and
they suck
yeah i agreed sir so
even if they offer a 403 b match
if they take it if they offer a match
take a match but you're they're not
matching your rollover
anyway sure i agree they would only
match what you're putting in
so now that's different than your annual
i'm talking about when you leave
never roll it to the next company always
roll it to an individual
an ira an individual retirement account
does that make sense
yes sir that makes me different so you
end up with a stack of 10 of those if
you had 10 different jobs
you know so i've got an ira i've got a
an old sep uh i've got an old
uh some other retirement thing that i
went defunct on
an old a simple and i've rolled them all
into a series of individual iras and
then i converted them to ross because i
was in a position to pay the tax when i
converted them to roths
but the point is never leave your old
retirement back behind you unless you're
forced to and never move it into the new
company
on and there's no case that you're
forced to do that yeah i had two four
three b's coming from uh the church
world yeah before i came here and i
wrote those into
an ira and individual irish exactly that
step
yeah yeah always bring it with you and
always put it in an ira
later you can convert that to a roth if
you have some extra money to pay the
taxes that that creates but right now
just move it into the ira
in good growth stock mutual funds
because when you're working with an ira
with a broker like a smart investor pro
you've got eight thousand choices not
four yep
yep yep or eight yeah or or whatever
so very interesting good detailed
question and uh
hey man the good news is you're paying
attention so you're not gonna mess this
up one way
i mean what you did was not horrible
this is just like
you did like an eight and i did like a
ten yeah that's all
you did not you didn't do like a two and
i did a ten okay you did a not a bad
thing
but all we did was just give it a little
more horsepower yeah cause you can pick
better mutual funds you got more control
of it
and you've got your broker looking over
it instead of just languishing over here
in an old 403 b
yeah that's good stuff chris is with us
in tampa florida hey chris
hey dave hey anthony how's it going guys
good better than we deserve sir how can
we help
so right now me and my girlfriend our
graduating seniors in college right now
and she will be graduating with about 45
000 worth of debt split between private
and
public student loans and i will not be
graduating with any
and my question was what is the best way
to help her
pay off all her debt let me tell you the
best way you can help her
is by not giving her a dime
and just by encouraging her to take her
debt seriously
um and the reason why that's the best
way man is you want to just protect
yourself protect your heart
um and then just encourage her along the
journey like hey
uh are you gonna take this serious you
know how can i encourage you
what are you gonna do about this debt
but do not hear me young man i hear it
in your heart
uh do not spend a dime of your money to
help pay off hers
build your foundation so if y'all do get
married
you can then help her then but for right
now
mind your business help her out and
she'll be all right how much student
loan debt she got
she is about 45 000. you pile up 45 000
in your savings account while you're
dating and
engaged and when you come back from the
honeymoon write a check and pay it off
yeah don't you pay off anybody's debt
that you're not married to yeah
period ever no exceptions
ever was that unclear not used real
clear okay
good this is the ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage eric and brianna are with us
hey guys how are you hey folks how are
y'all doing welcome welcome where do you
guys live
houston texas welcome to nashville how
much
debt did you two pay off we put off 75
000
in about two and a half years good for
you excellent
and your range of income during that 30
months we started at 65 went up to 115
and now we're down around 85. okay
sounds like a story there what kind of
debt did you have 75
000 well just student loans most people
who go to school for as long as i do
they they call them doctors
um it took me seven years to get my
bachelor's because anthony wasn't around
whenever i
was going through that time and i i
missed out on all the good advice
oh man i love it good for you man that's
fun what do you guys do for a living
i'm an engineer and i own my own baking
business
baking wow very cool yum good stuff
all right so 75 000 worth of student
loans mainly on the engineer
yeah yeah and uh are totally on the
engine total well yeah she had a little
small
but like 16 were mine oh but a dash of
salt
right yeah okay all right good
what happened 30 months ago what lit you
guys up to do this this is pretty
impressive
well we'd uh we'd gotten married we're
heading going through our pre-marriage
counseling and
and we had a lot of good influences
around us who advised us on on some of
the same things you talk about on how
money can be one of the biggest
stressors on a marriage and so that's
something that we wanted to attack
together
um get you know beneath us and behind us
as we you know
looked at uh the future together amen
i love it i love it what how what what
alone this journey
uh what would you say what was the
hardest thing to do
no fun we said no a lot like dave says
no is a complete sentence
yeah um and that's something we had to
do an awful lot i mean no to
multiple family trips and friends wanted
to eat out all the time we had a 25
a month eat out budget which basically
pay for some fast food and maybe ice
cream if we uh
we didn't get the extra fries and so we
kept it really tight for
for two and a half years yep yeah wow
good for you guys was it worth it
oh yeah gosh absolutely absolutely
absolutely
all right so you're getting pre-marriage
counseling somebody says money's the
biggest problem don't have that problem
work on it
and you said okay then how'd you what
did you do next
well i don't like spending money to
begin with
so it wasn't hard for me um for me
i was like yeah let's do this he's like
oh okay yeah
well let's we'll do it yeah we we got a
plan we sat together and we we
deal detailed out well like you said
mostly my debt and
we looked at what it was going to take
monthly to pay that off and um
you know she kept me honest and we just
got after it together it was the first
thing we did and really there wasn't
much conversation it was just
we were pulling the pulling the sled in
the same direction gotcha how'd you get
in touch with us
so you were a constant companion on
nymph's family road trip so i appreciate
that all growing up you were the
sixth family member in the car as we
drive from houston to
ohio and houston to arizona to visit
family listen to the radio
for years um and i had to listen uh to
financial peace in high school oh okay i
had nothing
too too forced yeah forced in the car
ride when you're a kid and i was in
school you noticed she said i had to
in high school it was a requirement
it was required to graduate i know
that's awesomeness yeah
and so you already knew this stuff and
so when he started talking about it it
was easy to plug into our stuff oh yeah
yeah okay because it already been around
you for a generation that's exactly yeah
very good now do you think um that
we should force all of our students in
america to do what you did
yeah could you at least hear that you
need to save money or there's a better
path than just
what you hear from everybody else like
oh it's just a car payment
it's good and so for me my mom was like
no we don't need to do that like you
don't need to do that yeah you have to
go into student loan debt because my mom
never went to college but um
i was like well i just heard this guy
say it's not good um
she was like it's okay it's okay um she
goes
you can pay it off after and i was like
yeah well i have no other option
but you had just a tiny one just tiny
versus the guy who
listens to it on vacation got nothing he
got nothing
yeah i just immediately decided to go
out of state for school and
the whole mess and you know multiple
different institutions and didn't know
what i wanted to do
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is you guys are
amazing congratulations thank you so
proud of you appreciate that well we've
got to be pulling the same direction
um this wasn't you know her dragging me
or me dragging her through it it's
something that we both wanted
um that's the other thing we had a why
um you know ken coleman talks about if
if you if your why doesn't make you cry
it's not your why or something at least
to that effect and that's something that
we believe in we
we saw what life after debt looked like
and we saw what
the future could hold and you know with
the way god's blessed us with their
income and with our future possibilities
we didn't want them to be hampered we
wanted to be able to bless people
further on down the line
okay so why then come up and then come
back down oh gosh i worked
oh your hours hours yeah you just went
back to a fairly normal exam yeah
that's exactly it yeah yeah and then a
bunch of side gigs i mean dog sitting
and house sitting and
and yeah
and a lot of the crazies gone now you're
back to fairly normal pretty much and
where are you guys at now in the baby
steps
uh we're paying off our actually we're
three four five we're saving up for a
down payment on our
our uh uh first house yeah
excellent job i'm proud of you who were
your biggest cheerleaders
we were friends jake and jen uh friends
aiden friend
uh hunter and lisa and then our family
they were just they were wonderful a lot
of
church small groups things like that
very cool good for you
so proud of you very well done we've got
a copy of rachel cruz's book for you the
latest new york times bestseller to come
out of ramsey press it's called know
yourself
know your money you'll both love it it's
perfect for this situation you guys are
incredible i'm so proud of you
all right here they are eric and brianna
houston texas
75 000 paid off in 30 months making 65
to 115
now back to normal at 85. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one work that fake
this is how it's done baby
yeah you know the today day we've had
two debt-free screams
and the common thread that i'm hearing
through both of them is all of them had
a very detailed why
the last one was like hey i didn't want
my daughter to grow up with
you know this struggle um then theirs is
we wanted our marriage to be healthier
not perfect but at least healthier yeah
and the
and in every case the side benefit
the mathematical implication is that
when you don't have any payments
you become wealthy yep if you pay
attention and start investing
yes sir and it's really not rocket
science the average person
will change jobs 12 times over the
course of their life
and a lot of times nowadays people
change jobs like they change clothes
but if they keep doing their iras they
keep doing their 401 case
they keep investing because they don't
have if you just invest a car payment
you'll have millions of dollars
if you'll stay out of the car payment
business that alone
will cost you a million dollars but you
get rid of sally mae and give her her
eviction notice
and you learn to be intentional and you
learn to walk side by side with your
spouse
it changes everything you sit down with
one of these smart investor pros
they can show you then how to take that
money now you can fund your kids college
now you know and here's the thing people
that have not gotten out of debt
and that just talk they don't ever do
anything
yeah 98 of the people that you survey
i'm making this number up
but you know almost everyone you ask ask
them if saving for your kids college is
important they almost everybody says yes
yes
yeah you know how many people actually
do it maybe what
10 less i'd say i'd say five to ten
percent five to ten percent
gotcha actually save money for their
kids college everybody else is a
freaking theory
yeah it's something well that'd be a
good thing to do someday
uh someday someday i'll write that book
why don't you get up off here someday
seriously and go do something oh my gosh
these guys are incredible i'm so proud
of them
hey if you text invest to 33 789 folks
text invest to 33789 you'll get one of
the smart investor pros
because here's the thing the reason to
get out of debt is so that you can
invest
the reason to invest is so that you
change your family tree
and you retire with golden rocking
chairs baby and you don't have to you
know
you don't have to worry about eating
alpo living on social insecurity
with too much month left at the end of
the money when you're 83
and you can't freaking make your light
bill
because you haven't done because you
gave it all the car company yes
you gave it all to master yes card you
work monday through friday labor to give
someone else a fruit of your labor
that's exactly what happens that's why
we call that that's why the bible calls
it the slave
to the lender yep the borrower is slave
to the lender it's more than just a
metaphor it is a mathematical freaking
fact yes this is the ramsey shadow
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
debt-free degree is my co-host today
here on the ramsey show the phone number
is triple eight eight two
five five two two five tom is in san
antonio hey tom how are you
good thank you dave uh i had a question
about um
a property that i sold a year ago
we had an agreement they made a 10-year
loan and i'm
financing it for them but we had an
agreement that
they would be able to pay it off after
two years um
they've paid up to exactly one year so
far
and i just want to know now they're
wanting to pay it all off
and uh if they pay it all off now i
think the interest i would lose would be
about 45 000
and i'm wondering if i should go ahead
and uh take the money and invest it or
stick out for the next year
wow so you're charging what kind of
interest rate
six and a half percent wow
okay and so this is like uh eight
hundred thousand dollar loan
um the actual loan amount was 708 yeah
750 so about seven or nine
okay so 45 000 is the interest for one
year at six and a half
but they've gotten been able to get a
loan better than six and a half
well they wanted to they wanted to pay
it off sooner anyway and
my attorney decided it would be
beneficial if we say we'll even pay off
early but not
until at least two years and they agree
to that
okay so i don't know if they're getting
along somewhere else or they've just got
the money
okay it's a commercial property and uh
the
the when when i owned it the occupants
were paying eight thousand dollars a
month rent
and their the people who bought it their
payment to me is about 4 700
a month mm-hmm they've gotten another
loan
okay um just took them a while to get a
bank
ah
i didn't even think of that then i guess
that would make sense with six and a
half percent
interest they probably got a much better
interest rate yeah i wouldn't take much
um in a three percent world um
trying to think what i would do if i
found myself in this case okay here's
your down here here's what's running
through my head i'll just go ahead and
say it all out loud so you can kind of
calculate it with me tom okay
um sure number one there's the forty
five thousand dollars that you would
have gotten
had they taken it all the way through
two years uh what's the
how much did they put down they put down
uh let's see the selling price was 750.
okay so you've got a loan almost equal
you've got a loan very close to equal to
what the property's
worth right so you don't want this
property back
no no the main reason i sold is because
it's in el paso and i'm 550 miles away
in san diego you don't want it back i
mean if they
put down 200 000 and you could take it
back for 500 and do it again
you dude i'd take that right but you
don't have any equity here
you're not going you know so yeah
they're not threatening
to hand you the keys but i'm just saying
uh that that kind of tells me how much
hardball you want to play
not much because you don't want this
thing back we want to work this out
okay so what i would do is say um
i was supposed to get another 45 000 out
of you guys
in interest um i will let you pay it off
early and negotiate a prepayment
penalty that is not 45 000
but less i thought about that and i was
thinking maybe you'd throw up
maybe half
i might even say 20. say if you you know
if you'll pay me half of what you were
going to pay me
they're probably if they're getting
three percent that's still
it doesn't really save me money doesn't
save money close enough though
i mean 15 to 20 if you could get the
information out of them in the
discussion as to what they're doing
and what their interest rate is then it
would tell you how much it's gonna save
them
like if they got a two percent then
they'd say four and a half you can
calculate
out don't take the whole four and a half
but take a chunk of it right
but if they're getting if they're
getting a four percent and they're two
and a half and you're offering and the
savings you're offering them is
equal to three they're not going to do
that
i don't know how i'd find that that
information i would ask
yeah you think they would just tell me
yeah i'd just say why are you paying it
off
oh you got another loan code what was
the rate you got on the new loan i'm
glad you were able to get a better rate
because i want to work this out with you
i don't want to charge you the whole
interest as a prepayment i want to let
you go and i'd love to have my money i
got some other stuff i can do with it
but let's work this out for a win-win
where we kind of meet in the middle
okay and don't charge them up don't
charge them a penalty that is greater
than their savings
right there you go right i get it
and okay so if we come to an agreement
um then i should probably have my
attorney drop
the thing yeah it should be a one-page
thing
it's it's really a release provision i
agree to release the thing
and i'll give you a deed release on this
i'll release and cancel the note
uh for a payment of x plus x penalty
the actual principal balance plus a
penalty of twenty one thousand dollars
or a penalty of seventeen thousand
dollars or
whatever you come to agreement to right
yeah
that seems fair yeah they're getting out
and you're not you're not gonna take all
of it
um because i bet you they're not saving
45 000
by the way by doing this year early
they're thinking that you're just gonna
go hey i want my money
which most people do by the way um so
nothing wrong with what you're doing
i'm trying to take a little a little
tougher stand
uh just because it sounds like they have
a real reason to do this but there's
nothing wrong with asking
i just like having a great conversation
because if i get information i can
design a deal
that's good for them and good for me
right
i see i'm not trying to screw them i'm
just trying to design something because
if i was trying to screw them i would
just go 45 000 bucks right because
and they're not going to pay you off
then they're going to sit there another
year
uh because they're not i'm guaranteeing
you they didn't get a rate low enough on
a commercial building of 700 000
loan cheap enough that they're saving 50
cents on the dollar here now dave let me
ask you this question
would it be a bad idea let's say if they
come back say yeah we got an interest
rate for three and a half percent
would it be bad to just renegotiate the
contract with him and say all right i'll
go down to three percent
don't you all sign up at least a five
they need i'd let them go and get their
new loan
because they might lose the loan over
the coming year uh or they might
the rates might tick up over the coming
year it could change the deal
but that wouldn't be a bad thing either
if it was a longer than one year
yeah i might consider just lowering my
rate if you want to be in the mortgage
business now that's the other side tom
of this discussion okay is if you
push this and you end up with this
property back
that's a bad thing okay okay uh that's
why i don't carry notes back when i sell
property i will sell a property cheaper
as long as i get all my money yeah than
if i carry a note back
the only way i want to carry a note back
is what we used to call in the business
happy happy loans
okay and a happy happy loan is you get a
good enough interest rate
and what she did he got a great interest
six and a half in this market is a
booming interest rate right absolutely
um and you get enough of a down payment
that you're happy if they pay because
you love the interest rate and you're
happy if they don't pay
because you're happy to take the
property back yep and so if you put 200
000
down on this deal and i'm getting it
back for 500 it's worth 750
i'm not mad about taking it back because
i can make money on the on the flip
again
yeah but uh the he's not got any margin
yeah i'm taking it back because he
didn't get enough of a down payment i
like it
now here's another question dave and i'm
asking because i'm learning i'm learning
going
on the ramsay show um and
charge it to my head if i ask the wrong
question i'm asking the learning
i'm debt free got my money you know all
that and if i go out there and do
something like that and charge someone
interest it
do you suggest that people know that or
not no i would not do that
because i think you can take that cash
and make more than six and a half on it
i got you
either by buying more real estate you
make a better rate of return than that
if you're careful
yeah and or investing in good mutual
funds you can make a better rate of
return
than that if you're careful there you go
i thought so and so
and uh while that property is going up
in value
your notes not changing it's actually
going down
so you're better off to if you're going
to collect payments off a building
you're better off to collect rent and be
the owner yes then you are collect
payments off a note
and so uh but but if you're gonna carry
a note then get a good
high interest rate and get a good strong
down payment happy happy loan
happy on both ends but i don't recommend
that that's why i don't carry it yeah
cause i figure if i'm gonna sit here and
worry about whether somebody's gonna pay
me monthly
yeah i'm gonna worry about the renter
while this thing's going up in value
right and i get the upside yeah so you
don't get any upside once you step out
or the ownership role and become the
bank gossip just wanted to ask
it's a good question it's a good
discussion and uh it's something to
think through there's
this is a that's an unusual question in
these times because interest rates are
so low very few people
carry back owner terms in this situation
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey guys this is kelly associate
producer for the ramsay show
did you know that over 16 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listed on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
daveramsey.com
[Music]
show
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
debt-free degree
is my co-host today i am dave ramsey
your host thank you for
joining us open phones at triple eight
eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in and we'll talk to you about
your life and your money marissa
is with us marissa is in portland oregon
hi marissa how are you
i'm good thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
uh so my husband got a life insurance
policy before we were married
and it's one of those policies where
he paid into it and then it had some
sort of investment
so it has a 30 000
cash out right now and we've since
obtained
two other policies for him that are way
cheaper per month and
give us more in life insurance it gives
us the 10 times
his income yeah you got term insurance
and you're getting rid of this crap
good right yeah yeah this one pays is
267 dollars a month so i've actually
stopped paying on it
but we still have this 30 000 cash out
and so i talked with
an edward jones person i was thinking of
putting it either in an ira or in our
kids college funds but she suggested
transferring it over to a long-term care
insurance policy
why how old are you how old are you guys
he's 42. oh you need a different broker
your broker's broken brokers maybe
it didn't yeah it didn't sound right to
me um and
so i'm trying to make a commission you
need a new broker
okay so so here's the thing here's the
thing
there's their long-term care insurance
nursing home insurance
your chance of using that before 60
years old is almost zero
statistically right okay so you don't
buy it until you're 60 but if you're 60
unless you got 10 million dollars you
buy it okay
okay now having said that there are two
types of long-term care insurance out
there floating around
originally when the concept came out and
it is an excellent concept to take care
of nursing home
above 60 is simply like
health insurance you just pay a monthly
premium and if you get sick they pay
your hospital
long-term care insurance you pay a
monthly premium and if you need
care in-home and your policy provides
for in-home care
or you go to the nursing home and your
policy provides for nursing home they
pay
the nursing home right that's what you
pay you pay and they pay that's the
thing
the newer kind is where anytime the
insurance business starts bundling
something you're getting really get
screwed
with the exception of bundling
homeowners and car you do want to bundle
that but everything
else you're trying to bundle investments
with insurance you're about to get
screwed long-term care has now started
selling a product
like that crappy whole life policy
you're getting rid of where it has an
investment element to it
and you can put a bunch of money in it
and then you never think about long-term
care again and so this
agent's trying to take your 30 000 bucks
and put it in one of these whole life
type
uh long-term care policies where you're
gonna do an upfront payment
and you're about to get screwed right
okay again
so that's why i'm telling you not only
don't do it but run because there's only
one reason that agent would recommend
that are two reasons one is they can't
add
or two they're crooked okay because it's
bad it's a bad
bad bad product and they can't add or
they don't
or they put their commission ahead of
what's best for you you don't need to
work with them anymore
immediately and it's not because of the
brand you mentioned i'm not mad at
edward jones
there's doofuses at almost every company
and you ran into a doofus
so um the um what what should we do with
the 30
000. you cannot roll it to an ira you
can take it out and
invest it but long-term
whole life life insurance is not pre-tax
you can't roll it to an ira
now you could take it out and invest it
in a mutual fund in your name
or you could take it out and invest it
in mutual funds for your kids college
and you know do a 529 or something which
is probably what i would do
if you're on baby step five you'll get a
decent rate of return that way yeah
okay well we have not the only debt we
have left is the house
that was the other thought is if i take
that out and you could throw it at the
house
you started the house or you can throw
it at the kids college but you don't
need to throw it at retirement you're
already doing 15
towards retirement right yeah right
larissa do you have
yeah do you have anything invested into
your car
your kids college fund not a whole lot
that's one area that we've
kind of slacked on so
they're uh eight and 11. yeah i would do
it
i would click smart vester pro at uh
dave
at daveramsey.com ramseysolutions.com
and you'll find um the the smart
investors there
and sit down with you they're not gonna
try to sell you crap like this they do
stuff
the way we teach here consistent with
that and with the heart of a teacher
where you understand it
by the way let me tell you this you have
a really good nose because you smelled a
rat
you didn't know how stinky the rat was
but you smelled a rat
and you something didn't feel right yeah
and i want you to learn to go with that
feeling that's a really good feeling to
listen to
yeah it's called the holy spirit
speaking to you absolutely and
god god's kind of whispering in your ear
don't do it yeah if it feels
funny you know why because it's funny
if it feels weird you know why it's
because it's weird
that's why it feels that way and we need
to learn to trust ourselves
in that kind of thing especially when
you got a good nose for it like marissa
does
yeah very very good stuff all right
anthony let's stop for a second do a
little
class on long-term care i pulled out my
cheap sheet here
okay i need to get that too the average
claim
on long-term care is 4.2 years
so when someone goes into a nursing home
they on average pay 4.2 years
which means a whole bunch paid less time
a whole bunch pay more time but the
average so the chances of you paying a
nursing home for 10 years is almost zero
in other words okay
okay and uh but a lot of people do go in
and a year two years three years they
pass away
yeah so but 4.2 is the average 17
of the claims are all that lasts more
than five years wow
so from 4.2 to 5 it gets rid of 83
of the people wow okay so if you got a
five-year policy
you're probably okay yes like 87
of the time right yeah in other words
statistically
so that's one thing you want to look at
you do always when you're getting
long-term care want to get an
in-home care feature because you can get
in-home care many times cheaper than a
nursing home and
it's not unusual for the quality to be
better because it's like having a
personal trainer instead of being in a
weight class with a bunch of people okay
right in other words you've got somebody
right there you've got a nurse coming in
checking on you right your kind of stuff
that whole kind of thing so look for
that uh it doesn't hurt to look for an
inflation kicker
that kicks it up the coverage kicks up a
little bit every year but the cost kicks
up a little bit every year
and um so you need to get the term
long-term life insurance unless you have
a very high
high net worth okay and you said 10
million
i just made that up but i mean it could
be 5 million if you want the bottom line
is do you want to do you have the cash
to pay for the nursing home
got you out of pocket 60 years old
and before the chances of you going into
a nursing home are like 0.00
something percent it's almost nothing
wow but every day you live after 60 it
goes up
now i've got hundreds of millions of
dollars in real estate right i'm
60 i'm not buying long-term care
insurance right we'll hire a nurse to
take care of old dave if he goes out of
his head
and somebody will take care of him i
hope one of these people around here i
make sure every day
i might get accused of being out of my
head sooner rather than later
but it is a vital part of financial
planning only
after you're 60. we've strongly
recommended at that point for
most people's setting this is the ramsey
[Music]
shop
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the ramsey show anthony
o'neil ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book debt
free degree
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life
and about your money jared is with us in
los angeles hi jared how are you
i'm good mr ramsay how you doing better
than i deserve what's up
hey i was calling cause uh sadly my wife
and i found you guys a little too late
but in december of 2020 we got into a
fleece
and we want to get out of that and
currently we are on
baby step number two but the problem is
we have we put all of our savings and
got down to the thousand dollars of
emergency funds towards our debt to pay
off
credit card in one debt so now we have
at least that now i see that we should
get out of immediately
yeah we don't know the next steps we
should take um
okay well we've got to gather up some
numbers to ascertain the damage
yes sir all right um the first number is
you call the fleece company and you ask
them what the early buyout
is which is effectively your payoff for
today have you already done that
yes sir it is uh 38
740. okay and so this is a long-term
fleece isn't it how
was it a five-year uh it's only a
three-year a three-year okay 38 000.
have you looked up the value of the car
yet
yes uh it's it's because it's a 2021
kbb actually doesn't even have it can't
even give you the value so i looked at a
2021
2020 it's a honda odyssey the 2020
if i trade it in it's 34 000 if i go
private party
the range is 36 to 38. okay okay
so yeah um hypothetically if you could
sell to an individual then you could
probably get out of it whole right
because if you can sell it for 38 and
you can give the fleece company 38
and they give the title to you then
you've got your deal and you're out
right
yes and that's that's the that's the
goal here
um that may be tough for two reasons
one is it's freaking brand new and two
is if somebody's gonna buy a brand new
car they're gonna buy a brand new car
uh and uh two is it's a very expensive
car because it's
you know forty thousand bucks and not a
lot of people walking around forty
thousand bucks in their pocket uh
buying off of craigslist uh when you get
much
when you get much up above twenty
something you start to get a little bit
less
transactions private sale yeah a lot of
these transit a lot of transactions then
a dealer
of some kind involved um
okay so it sounds like you probably get
a dealer to pick it up for like 34 36
maybe right
yes leave you a couple grand in the hole
what's your household income
uh 138 000 well that's good enough yeah
okay
well the only thing i would know to do
is to stop the um
stop the debt snowball temporarily and
pile up the cash to get
out to get this transaction done and
then you've got to figure out a way to
get the car
sold to someone for somewhere in that 36
range hopefully and you put
you know you're going to need another
car obviously and so
if we budget five seven thousand or
whatever for a car
and we need three for this you need ten
grand to do this it's going to take you
a couple months to gather that up right
yes i have uh the problem is we we got a
van which our
already was humbling you know but we
have three kids
i mean you bought the bentley of vans
the honda odyssey i mean yeah
yeah i know it's so funny it's a
fabulous car i mean rachel cruz will
sell you one she likes hers
she can she could be a honda salesman
i'm telling you is that what she got it
was honda honestly wasn't it
uh in the video yeah that was odd
odyssey yeah
sharon rachel's is yeah yeah okay i
thought it was i thought it was you know
so anyway yeah she she thinks it's the
best car since sliced bread but yeah
i actually love it now it just took me a
while to relax yeah i mean it's that
it's that whole thing you move into the
van
stage of life yeah that's a tough move
some midlife crisis looking for a place
to happen
but uh yeah so anyway aside from that
yeah you've got to figure out a way to
replace this thing now how much debt do
you have other than this
so outside of the lease we have 95 000.
what is that student loans no it's
uh we got solar panels on our house
as well as a heloc okay okay and he
locks more
less than half your annual income right
yes
okay yeah so you we're looking at a
hundred and
uh thirty thousand bucks and you make a
hundred and thirty
and so if you could be debt-free in two
years and keep the car that might be a
possibility too
just keep paying the fleece until you're
debt-free and then once you're debt-free
pay the fleece off early
buy it on out for yourself and keep it
if your wife loves the car and you
are thinking the van is cool now yeah i
mean you could treat you treat it like a
car
debt i wouldn't have signed you up for
this thing okay
for a lot of reasons but uh uh but but
you're there
now and getting out of it's gonna cost
you 10 grand out of pocket
in in a replacement car minimum a little
seven thousand dollar van of some kind
um and you've got this really high
income so what kind of trajectory is
your income on is it going to shoot up
from here
yes it's still i'm supposed to get a
raise this year
we were thinking of getting out of the
lease because now i feel stupid
and getting a cheaper car um because
in the long term we don't think we want
to buy this car we rather get something
that we can hold for a long time that we
it's something
cheaper but we wanted to see your
opinion i i'm fine
i'm fine getting out of it i was trying
to i'm trying to figure out a way if it
is there a scenario in which you keep
the thing is what i was trying to figure
out but now that you're there
but uh but if you want out of it that's
how you get out of it you got to pay the
difference
in what somebody will give you and 38
yes and then you've got to also have on
top of that money to get something to
drive
yeah so what are you driving i have a
paid off huh
uh toyota camry how many kids do you
have
we have three kids five three one okay
so you're into another used van of some
kind right
an suv or something yeah right yes okay
all right well you you can do this um
but you're gonna have to buy a nice
enough van that it because this is as
nice as your car
that it becomes it becomes her car
because the federal law is mama gets a
good car i was just about to say that
that's what i want i want her to get the
good time yeah so that you know it's a
ten thousand dollar move here
yeah okay so how quick can you stretch
together 10k
if you stop everything if i stop
everything
uh and that that's what we're trying to
figure out i figured
we learned that i eat too much so i
gotta stop that
well that that's really not a financial
thing no
no i eat so much
yeah me too chocolate doughnuts but
what's that got to do with money okay
now you're getting perfect i think 10
000 um
we can get done in six months to eight
minutes no i think you can do it in
three yeah i was about to say man you
make 130 right
how much is this fleece payment the
police payment is 5.85
that's not as bad as i thought i was
gonna guess seven okay good
all right good okay yeah i mean tighten
that budget up and let
because the quicker you get this thing
done the faster you can get started on
your dead snowball without the 500
coming out
the faster you're going to be out of
debt and so i i
you know if you're ever going to turn up
the heat to white hot intensity
you know blue flame level baby it would
be to get rid of the van
yeah because the fat and the by the way
the faster you get rid of it the
the the more it's going to bring i mean
if you wait six months this car is not
going to bring anywhere near what it'll
bring today
right yeah so we need to get out of this
thing
pronto yeah as a matter of fact if you
have the ability to borrow the 10 000 i
probably would do it and just get it
done
because you're going from 38 000 down to
10.
yeah yeah i would i would go ahead and
do that if you can find a deal where you
do a trade-in and walk out with a usable
seven thousand dollar van and you eat
the three
and so you have a 10 000 loan and that
car dealer set you up with a little car
loan
i'd do that deal because that's moving
down
in debt yeah yeah because we're going to
go down obviously in a lot of cars
a bunch but you're going from but you're
going you know you're cutting your debt
by 75
on this from 40 to
10. 10. i think i did that math right
yeah close enough 30 grand yeah you
right there
[Music]
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
jordan and natalie are with us hey guys
how are you we're great hi how are you
welcome where do you live bakersfield
california
wow a bit of a trip to nashville yep
kind of wild times to be coming in out
of california
yeah it's uh it's nice to be out here
it's a little different
like we're like walking around like
normal people yeah like normal
are they gonna let you back in yeah it
wouldn't be the worst thing if they
didn't but
all right how much debt have you guys
paid off uh we paid off 350 000
holy wow how long did that take it took
three years and three months
whoa three years and three months way to
go and your range of income during that
time
um it was 270 to 310
excellent what do you guys do for a
living i'm a journeyman lineman
i'm a stay-at-home mom uh-huh so you're
working all the time aren't you
lots of time 30 hours 40-hour lots of
yeah lots of hours yeah you've been
kicking it man yeah
wow so was there an apprenticeship to do
that absolutely yeah there's a five-year
apprenticeship i went through and then
became a journeyman
okay because yeah because you're making
some bank there but you're working hard
yes sir yeah we love it well done well
done
what kind of debt was the 350 000 that
was our house
you paid off your house yeah in
california yeah
i'm looking at weird people man
oh that is that doesn't matter how old
are you two
i'm 29 and 31. with a paid for house in
bakersfield california yeah
mic drop that's pretty incredible guys
thank you wow that's awesome so tell us
the story what inspired you to do this
um well it started a little ways before
the three years and three months my
parents got me
the total money makeover when i was 20.
and it just started working
actually making some money and you know
got credit cards had a car loan and
i read that book and um it just
i stopped all that and then uh we got
married
and had we had no consumer debt at that
point then we bought a house
um that we stayed in for a few years and
then
wanted to move into a house that we'd be
in for the next 20 years or so until the
kids were out of college and everything
and
and buckled down said hey we we don't we
don't want any of this
around for our kids and and uh just
knocked it out as fast
as we possibly could wow so the
jump from 270 to 310 was that you just
taking a bunch of overtime or is that
your normal increases
it's just uh all over time even just up
to
that's way more than my base you know i
just was working
all of it was over yeah just working
working working yeah okay how many hours
a week were you working during that
three years
um it averaged like 65 but there was
lots of weeks or
80 100 you know wow some good pay
but a lot of long hours right and that
that's hard work too i mean
that's not that's not like 80 hours
sitting at a desk climbing climbing
poles and towers and
stuff like that in the rain and so the
fires out there in california so that
was
you know a little it can get dangerous
yeah yeah we can but
we uh we get good training and and i'm
i'm pretty damn good at what i do there
you go yeah
i like that good for you man and you
haven't paid for a house
yes sir so what's this house worth uh
550.
wow that is so neat
i'm sorry i mean i'm just sitting here
just i'm looking at millennials
um and i'm seeing how she's holding your
hand real tight brother because
she got a good looking man who paid off
the house what would you say as a young
couple was the hardest thing throughout
this journey
i would say the time that we had to
sacrifice without
jordan there and just meet with the kids
and yeah
yeah how many kids you got we have three
kids what ages
eight six and one oh yeah you had a big
job too
yes you're like a journeyman mother yeah
yeah
that's pretty serious i mean and he's
gone i mean he's just gone
80 hours i mean he's not there he's
there to sleep and leave again that's it
exactly yeah wow so sharon said when we
were starting this business she was a
single mom with a husband
i was gone working like you were working
you know i mean it was for
about three years you know about the
same thing you did but it set us on it
set us into a trajectory
that we never went back to because of
that that the momentum you create off of
this a slingshot
for decades into your future yeah
exactly well done you guys
so how's it feel to have no payments in
the world of freaking 30 years old wow
it's surreal it's it's awesome too like
i i love what i do and i really enjoy
working but not that much you know so
the phone rings now
and i'm like we we have dinner plans or
we're doing something with the kids i'm
like
oh i'll just hang out with the family
now you know and so it's been
it's just such a blessing not to have
any burden of of any kind you know
where you were taking everything before
everything i was the guy if they if they
needed
if the power was out they called me you
know that's simple
yeah when you're sitting down with your
kids when they are 20 21 years old
and you tell them why to avoid debt what
would be that reason
just because um it just robbed us of
the time that that we could just be
together as a family
and it just was an extra burden like i
had all these worries about
you know i didn't i mean we didn't have
any other bills but just
i don't know there was something inside
me that just didn't want to have to pay
anyone else besides ourselves and our
future and my kids
future and um and uh
i don't know i guess it's hard to
explain yeah natalie
natalie what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of that is
just staying focused and um for us
it was we had a lot of talks about the
things that we could do
when we were done so just motivating
each other and encouraging each other
that it's just temporary
to push past yeah yeah gratification
push through these 60 and 80 hour weeks
yeah yeah the initial plan was
like seven years 50k a year you know
that's how we wrote it out
and then uh once we got going we're like
well if we just dig deeper and cut
deeper
we can cut this time down and be done
you know just
see the other side and see that light
yeah when you can see 3.3 years
you can stretch for it yeah reach for
the tape exactly
i like it well congratulations we're
very very proud of you you're an
impressive young couple if you just take
what was a house payment you're going to
be wealthy
yeah very very wealthy from 30 to 65. i
mean that's
pretty stinking incredible so uh you
you're going to be in an
amazing place and yeah i changed your
family tree
if the kiddos get the message about hard
work and living on less than you make
and avoiding debt
and this is how our family became
wealthy if they get that message
then they will then they'll carry it
into the other generations
they'll get it it's not going to be
optional for a long time so
they'll get it all right i like it
that's
very good i love it well we've got a
copy of rachel cruz's book know yourself
know your money for you guys and uh
that'll be part of the continuation of
this whole process for you that's our
latest new york times bestseller from
ramsey press
so good good stuff all right jordan and
natalie from bakersfield california
350 000 paid off house and everything
they're weird
they did it in three years and three
months making 270 to 310 with 85 hour
weeks
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
this is exactly how it's done it's not
often i'm speechless dave
[Applause]
that's true this is that's not often
they're amazing yes a young couple 31 29
years old said hey we're gonna
here's the other thing to take note
there's a lot of doctors and lawyers
that would trade income with him
absolutely
and they're 250 000 student loan debt
yes buying themselves
yeah i mean this guy he's killing it he
found a trade and he knows how to work
that trade
obviously went through the
apprenticeship to become a journeyman
and uh and is more than
providing for his family i mean they're
gonna be very wealthy yes sir i mean
they are very wealthy pretty incredible
yeah fun stuff
there's fun stuff yeah you're right
they're probably almost millionaires now
oh man half a day this is the ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
corinthians 4 18 so we fix our eyes not
on what is seen
but what is unseen since what is seen is
temporary but what is unseen is eternal
henry ford said obstacles are those
things you see when you take your eyes
off the goal well
taxes taxes taxes taxes
these days there's pretty much two ways
to do your taxes
either you do them yourself online if
they are simple
or you pay a tax pro if they're more
involved because the tax pro will pay
for themselves if you got a complicated
return
we are thrilled to offer ramsey smart
tax as a way to do them
online this year 50 000 people have
already chosen to do that
if your taxes are simple enough our
software can handle all the deductions
the standard one or if you've got enough
to make it worth your while even
itemized deductions and if things get
tricky
and you need an extension you can apply
for that directly in the software
if you want a refund let me remind you
refunds are a sign you overpaid
then they're going to give you back
because you overpaid that's all a refund
is you have a savings account with zero
interest at the government
but if you did overpay you should get
the refund we want to make sure you get
it
and we'll make sure you do without
charging you some ridiculous processing
fee like the other guys
so whether you need a pro or whether you
want to do it online with ramsey smart
tax we'll
we will set you up with it either way
without any side
hustle without any side thing going on
we're not going to try to sell you
something it's pretty simply help you
get your taxes done
text the word tax to 33 789
text tax to 33789
and elise is with us in provo utah hi
annelise how are you
hi doing good thank you good how can we
help
um so my question for you today so my
husband's looking back
looking at going back to school and
getting an emba
and while he's back in school we're
looking at me
um being a stay at home mom with two
kids
and we're just trying to decide whether
or not we should sell our house while he
is doing that
i'm out what are you gonna be living on
yeah
so we will be living on
he'll he makes around 52 000 a year so
it would be about 2 700 a month
okay so i'm sorry he's not i thought you
i got the impression he was quitting his
job he's not
no he's not quitting his job he will be
doing an executive mba
so he'll be working during the day going
to school at night
and then i'll just be at home and so why
do you have to sell your house
um because it would make our house
payments then be half of what we're
bringing in
during that time i know and i just know
whenever we've talked about he's like
well
i'm sorry i thought he was keeping his
job he is
he is but i will be getting rid of mine
oh
how much do you make so
why are you getting rid of your job so
he can go to school at night
um so i can stay home with the kids okay
so we have two goals at one time we're
trying to accomplish he wants to go back
to school and you want to quit to stay
home with the kids
all at the same time so there's nothing
to do with him going back to school has
to do with you quitting your job
um it work is it just to make it so we
don't have to do
child care currently i just work weekend
night but with them going back in school
you need more time to study that would
generally be the time
during the weekend that he would watch
them but he would now need that time to
be able to study
i don't think the house is a problem
here dave what do you think it is
i think they're trying to do too much at
one time
but you're saying the re you now work at
night and weekends right
yeah and so he keeps the kids and then
you don't work during the day and you
keep the kids while he's at work
yeah and the problem is him keeping the
kids at nights and weekends wouldn't
allow you to work anymore what do you
make
i make probably around thirty eight
thousand
what do you do here i'm a i'm a nurse
why don't you change shifts
yeah um
oh because if you either way you got
daycare right right
yeah it's the same day it's the same
difference i see and
it sounds like you really want to be
home and raise your kids
right now yes yeah so it's not because
the daycare bill is it's you you want to
be at home with your kids
well if you quit and come home you can't
afford this house so yeah you got to
sell it
now then let's decide whether he's going
back to school or not that's a separate
decision really
yep they've all gotten tangled up just
because of who takes care of the kids at
night that's the only reason they got
tangled up
the bottom line is when your income goes
away this is not a house you can afford
that's what you told us right yeah
yeah and so uh and you're gonna go rent
so you can stay home
watch your uh so when he quit when he
finishes the emba does that change his
income
automatically or just hopefully
um hopefully
it should hopefully change it to about
what both of us are making currently
that's a gamble how are you paying for
it
so his um work might pay for it or if
not we were going to save up to pay for
it okay
and is it a two-year program two-year
yep
well i mean the other option is do you
grit your teeth and you hang on with the
50
house payment for two years until his
income goes up but we don't even have a
guarantee his income is going to go up
at the end of that so
i do think you're moving down a house to
make this happen
okay it does it's not because other
here's the problem
you can hit goals but seldom can you hit
four of them at once
yeah and we've got the goal of this
house
we've got the goal of you being at home
and we've got the goal of him finishing
the nba right
and they're competing with each other
because they all affect money
in the house hold and so the
the least of the three is the home
ownership and that's why you went there
now i'm catching up with you is that
logical
yes yeah and then the next most
important is uh
either the nba or you staying at home
they're probably
somewhat equal in importance in euros
minds
both of them have to do with your future
so you're betting on the future here
yeah i think you move down and you get
in a real good solid position
and you have figured out how you're
going to pay cash no borrowing for this
mba that might work
yeah and um i i
i will tell you that that i am a fan i
said this in another hour of the day
already
i'm a fan of the emba programs i'm a fan
of education
um i am not a fan of you thinking it's
secret sauce and that somehow this is
going to make your future easy
it's not um i've got folks on our team
that are smarter than or more educated
than
uh and that make more money than
the mbas on our team make
but they don't have mbas and so it has
to do with your ability to develop
business acumen and your ability to go
out and leave the cave kill something
and drag it home
having letters after your name does not
mean you're going to be successful
90 of success has nothing to do with
that oh dave you're wrong that's what
america's saying
huh i'm a doctor i have an mba i am
successful
well i mean i'm just telling you the
character quality let me tell you let me
tell you what a broke doctor is one that
doesn't work much
that's what a broke doctor is you want a
law you know what you lawyers are a dime
a dozen
that don't make spit yes they're
everywhere
yeah and so it has to do with work ethic
perseverance
uh critical thinking skills the ability
to go in the marketplace observe
trends and step on them i mean this
stuff the mba can help you do that
yes the knowledge can help you do that
but this side what you don't want to
fall into is the trip that
the the trick that says oh the only
thing keeping you from being successful
is you don't have a degree
ah if that thought ever goes through
your head just yell at yourself wrong
okay is education important yes but is
that what's keeping you from being
successful
no we all know educated fools that are
broke
yep all of us know them they collect
degree they collect degrees like a
thermometer
i mean they're everywhere they're out
there all over the place don't be one of
those
and don't fall into that trap in your
mind that's what's holding you back
because it very seldom is
speaking true otherwise i wouldn't be
sitting here
without an mba doing this
so it's okay to get one but it's not a
magic pill it's not a silver boy
that puts us hour the dave ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you